¿Que soy una mujer de fe, una experta?
Tal vez una hermana,
o una mujer oprimida,
a la que han lavado el cerebro.
Una terrorista.
O un retraso en la cola de seguridad del aeropuerto.
Esto último es cierto.
(Risas)
Si su percepción ha sido negativa, no los culpo.
Es la forma en que los medios han retratado
a gente como yo.
Un estudio observó
que el 80 % de las noticias sobre el Islam y los musulmanes son negativas.
Hay estudios que muestran que la mayoría en EE.UU. no conoce a un musulmán.
Supongo que la gente no le habla a su taxista.
(Risas)
Bueno, para quienes no conocen a un musulmán,
encantada de conocerlos.
Les contaré quién soy.
Soy madre y me encanta el café.
Doble expreso, crema aparte.
Soy introvertida.
Me encanta estar en forma.
Y soy practicante espiritual musulmana.
Pero no como en la canción de Lady Gaga, porque no nací así.
Para mí fue una opción.
A los 17, decidí salir del armario.
No como gay, como algunos de mis amigos,
sino como musulmana.
Y decidí ponerme la hijab, cubriendo mi cabeza.
Mis amigas feministas se horrorizaron.
¿Por qué oprimirte?
Lo curioso es que para mí,
fue en ese momento una declaración feminista de independencia,
de la opresión que sentía a mis 17 años,
para ajustarme a los cánones inalcanzables de perfección y belleza.
No acepté pasivamente la fe de mis padres.
Luché contra el Corán.
Leí y reflexioné, cuestioné y puse en duda,
y en última instancia, creí.
Mi relación con Dios no fue amor a primera vista.
Fue una entrega confiada y lenta,
que se fue profundizando con cada lectura del Corán.
Su belleza rítmica, a veces me emociona.
Me veo a mí misma en él. Siento que Dios me conoce.
¿Alguna vez han sentido como si alguien los viera y comprendiera por completo?
¿Y que los ama igualmente?
Así me siento.
Y más adelante me casé.
Y como buena egipcia,
empecé mi carrera como ingeniera.
(Risas)
Tuve un hijo después de casarme.
En resumen, vivía el sueño egipcio-estadounidense.
Hasta esa terrible mañana de septiembre de 2001.
La mayoría seguramente recuerda exactamente dónde estaba esa mañana.
Yo estaba sentada en la cocina, terminando el desayuno.
Miré la pantalla del televisor, y vi las noticias.
Había humo, aviones que se estrellaban en los edificios,
gente que saltaba de los mismos.
¿Qué era todo eso?
¿Un accidente?
¿Algo funcionó mal?
Pasé rápidamente del shock a la indignación.
¿Quién haría algo así?
Cambio de canal y oigo:
"...terrorista musulmán",
"...en nombre del Islam",
"...descendiente de Oriente Medio",
"...yihad",
"...deberíamos bombardear La Meca".
Dios mío.
No tan solo habían atacado a mi país,
sino que, en un instante,
las acciones de otra persona, me convertían de ciudadana
en sospechosa.
Ese mismo día tuvimos que conducir, por el centro de Estados Unidos,
mudarnos a una nueva ciudad, para empezar la escuela.
Y recuerdo estar sentada, en el asiento del copiloto,
mientras conducíamos en silencio,
agachada lo máximo posible.
Por primera vez, tuve miedo de que alguien supiera que era musulmana.
Nos mudamos a nuestro apartamento esa misma noche en una nueva ciudad,
en lo que parecía un mundo totalmente diferente.
Y entonces escuchaba, y veía y leía,
las advertencias de las organizaciones nacionales musulmanas,
avisando cosas como: "Esté alerta", "Tenga cuidado",
"Permanezca en zonas iluminadas", "No se congregue".
Me quedé en casa toda la semana.
Y entonces fue viernes de esa semana,
el día que los musulmanes se congregan para rezar.
Y otra vez las advertencias: "No vaya este primer viernes,
podría ser un objetivo".
Y miraba las noticias, todas las noticias.
Las emociones estaban a flor de piel, lo cual es comprensible,
y también oía sobre los ataques a musulmanes,
o gente que parecía ser musulmana
a la que golpeaban en plena calle.
Las mezquitas eran bombardeadas.
Y pensé, mejor quedarse en casa.
Aún así, algo no parecía estar bien.
Porque los que atacaron nuestro país,
atacaron nuestro país.
Entiendo que la gente estuviese enojada con los terroristas.
¿Saben qué? Yo también.
Y tener que justificarse todo el tiempo no es fácil.
No me importan las preguntas. Me encantan las preguntas.
Son las acusaciones las que se hacen duras.
Hoy oímos decir a la gente cosas como:
"Hay un problema en este país y se llama musulmanes.
¿Cuándo vamos a deshacernos de ellos?"
Algunos quieren prohibir a los musulmanes y cerrar las mezquitas.
Hablan de mi comunidad como si fuera un tumor
en el cuerpo de EE.UU.
Y mi única pregunta es: ¿Somos malignos o benignos?
Ya saben, un tumor maligno, se extrae en su totalidad,
y un tumor benigno se monitoriza.
Este tipo de elección no tiene sentido, porque la pregunta es errónea.
Los musulmanes, como los demás ciudadanos no son un tumor en el cuerpo de EE.UU.,
somos un órgano vital.
(Aplausos)
Gracias.
Los musulmanes son inventores y profesores,
socorristas y atletas olímpicos.
¿En serio cerrar las mezquitas hará que Estados Unidos sea más seguro?
Podrá liberar algunas plazas de parking,
pero no acabará con el terrorismo.
Ir a la mezquita regularmente está asociado
con tener una visión más tolerante de las personas de distinta fe
y con un mayor compromiso cívico.
Y como un jefe de policía en la zona de Washington DC
me dijo recientemente,
la gente no se radicaliza en las mezquitas.
Se radicaliza en su sótano o habitación, delante de un computador.
Y lo que uno encuentra sobre el proceso de radicalización
es que empieza en línea,
pero lo primero que pasa
es que se le corta a la persona los vínculos con su comunidad,
hasta con su familia,
para que el grupo extremista pueda lavarle el cerebro,
y hacerle creer que los terroristas son los verdaderos musulmanes,
y que cualquiera que adore su comportamiento e ideología
es un fuera de serie y un apóstata.
Si queremos prevenir la radicalización,
tenemos que asegurar que la gente vaya a la mezquita.
Algunos argumentan que el Islam es una religión violenta.
Después de todo, un grupo como ISIS basa su brutalidad en el Corán.
Ahora como musulmana y madre, como ser humano,
creo que debemos hacer todo lo posible para detener a un grupo como ISIS.
Pero nos estaríamos dejando engañar por su discurso,
si los consideramos representantes de una fe de 1600 millones de personas.
(Aplausos)
Gracias.
ISIS tiene tanto que ver con el islamismo
como el Ku Klux Klan con el cristianismo.
(Aplausos)
Los dos grupos afirman que su ideología se basa en su libro sagrado.
Pero cuando los ves, no están motivados
por lo que han leído en su libro sagrado.
Es la brutalidad la que hace que lean estas cosas en la escritura.
Recientemente, un imam prominente me contó una historia que me sorprendió.
Me dijo que una chica se le acercó,
porque estaba pensando en unirse a ISIS.
Me sorprendió mucho y le pregunté
si ella había estado en contacto con algún líder radical religioso.
Y él respondió que el problema era más bien lo contrario,
que cada clérigo con el que había hablado le había dado la espalda
y dijo que su ira, su sentido de injusticia en el mundo,
le iba a traer problemas.
Sin manera de canalizar y dar sentido a su ira,
se convertía en un objetivo prioritario a explotar
por extremistas que le prometían una solución.
El imam la conectó de nuevo con Dios y con su comunidad.
No la avergonzó de su ira sino que le brindó formas constructivas
de hacer un cambio real en el mundo.
Lo que aprendió en esta mezquita, la salvó de unirse a ISIS.
Les he contado un poco
como la islamofobia me afecta a mí y a mi familia.
Pero ¿cómo impacta a cualquier estadounidense?
¿Cómo impacta a todos los demás?
¿Cómo consumir miedo 24 horas al día afecta a la salud de nuestra democracia?
¿Y a la salud de nuestro libre pensamiento?
Bueno un estudio, en realidad varios estudios en neurociencia,
muestran que cuando tenemos miedo, al menos suceden 3 cosas:
Somos más propicios a aceptar el autoritarismo,
la conformidad y el prejuicio.
Un estudio mostró que cuando los sujetos se exponían a nuevas historias
negativas sobre musulmanes,
eran más propicios a aceptar ataques militares en países musulmanes,
y políticas que limiten los derechos de los musulmanes estadounidenses.
Esto no es académico.
Si uno analiza cuándo empezó el sentimiento anti-musulmán,
entre 2001 y 2013,
pasó tres veces,
pero no cuando ocurrieron los ataques terroristas.
Fue en el periodo previo a la guerra de Irak, y durante dos ciclos electorales.
La islamofobia no es solo la respuesta natural al terrorismo musulmán,
como era de esperar.
Puede ser una herramienta de manipulación pública,
que erosiona las bases de una sociedad libre,
que son los ciudadanos racionales bien informados.
Los musulmanes son como canarios en las minas de carbón.
Seremos los primeros en sentirlo,
pero el aire tóxico del miedo nos está perjudicando a todos.
(Aplausos)
Y asignar una culpa colectiva,
no implica solo justificarse uno mismo todo el tiempo.
Deah y su mujer Yusor eran una joven pareja de recién casados
que vivían en Chapel Hill en Carolina del Norte,
donde los dos fueron a la escuela.
Deah era atleta.
Iba a un colegio de dentistas, tenía talento, prometía...
Y su hermana me decía que era el más dulce,
el ser humano más generoso que ella había conocido.
Ella estaba de visita y él le enseñó su curriculum;
y se quedó impresionada.
Dijo: "¿Cómo mi hermano pequeño se volvió un joven tan prometedor?"
Tan solo unas semanas más tarde de visitar a su hermano y a su mujer,
su vecino,
Craig Stephen Hicks,
los asesinó,
así como a la hermana de Yusor, Razan, que estaba de visita esa tarde,
en su apartamento,
una ejecución,
después de publicar declaraciones antimusulmanas en su Facebook.
Disparó a Deah ocho veces.
El fanatismo no es solo inmoral, puede ser letal.
Pero volviendo a mi historia.
¿Que pasó después del 11-S?
¿Seguimos yendo a la mezquita o nos mantuvimos a salvo en casa?
Bueno lo hablamos,
y parecerá una decisión insignificante pero para nosotros se trataba
de qué tipo de EE.UU. queríamos para nuestros hijos:
uno que nos controla por miedo
o uno donde podíamos practicar nuestra religión libremente.
Por lo que decidimos ir a la mezquita.
Y pusimos a mi hijo en el asiento del auto,
le atamos el cinturón y en silencio, condujimos intensamente a la mezquita.
Lo saqué del auto, me quité los zapatos, y anduve hasta la sala de oraciones.
Y lo que vi me detuvo.
El sitio estaba abarrotado.
Y el imam se dirigió a la multitud
dando la bienvenida y las gracias,
porque la mitad de la congregación
eran cristianos, judíos, budistas, ateos,
gente de fe y sin fe,
que habían venido no a atacarnos, sino a apoyarnos de forma solidaria.
(Aplausos)
En ese momento me emocioné.
Estaban ahí porque eligieron el valor y la compasión
sobre el pánico y el prejuicio.
¿Qué elegirían Uds.?
¿Qué elegirían en esos momentos de miedo y fanatismo?
¿Se mantendrían a salvo?
¿O se unirían a los que dicen
que somos mejor que todo eso?
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
Muchas gracias.
Helen Walters: Dalia nos has tocado la fibra sensible.
Pero me pregunto,
¿qué le dirías a los que argumentan
que estás dando esta charla TED,
que está claro que eres una persona de pensamiento profundo,
que trabajas en un prestigioso laboratorio de ideas,
que eres una excepción no la norma?
¿Qué le dirías a esa gente?
Dalia Mogahed: Les diría no dejen que el escenario los distraiga,
soy totalmente común.
No soy una excepción.
Mi historia no es inusual.
Soy tan común como cualquiera.
Cuando uno ve a los musulmanes en el mundo,
y es lo que he hecho, el estudio más amplio que se haya realizado
sobre los musulmanes en el mundo,
la gente quiere cosas comunes.
Prosperidad para su familia,
un trabajo,
y vivir en paz.
Por lo que no soy ninguna excepción.
Cuando encuentras gente que parece la excepción,
muchas veces es la norma la que se ha roto,
y no es que sean la excepción.
HW: Muchas gracias, Dalia Mogahed.
(Aplausos)